[Music]
what's up guys i'm phd here you know
there used to be entire youtube channels
dedicated big ones to just reviewing
cases you know laptop cases
iphone cases i never really got super
into that because i was like oh you know
how interesting could a case really be
i'm not a big case guy
but this is this has got to be the most
interesting case we've seen in a long
time this is the new apple magic
keyboard case for the new ipad pro 300
bucks for the small one and 350 bucks
for this bigger one and there was a lot
of hype for this case right it was
announced alongside this new ipad which
was
barely actually different from the
previous ipad pro but along with the new
mouse and cursor support on the ipad it
re-stoked this whole fire of
can the ipad pro be a full-time computer
so i've been using this new ipad and
this magic case as my primary computer
for the past couple days and all weekend
and the conclusion i've gotten to is
this is the best version of the ipad as
a computer for sure
but
i would still rather have a laptop
let me explain so for your money this is
actually a pretty substantial like nice
case there's a lot going on here it's a
top part full of magnets that locks onto
the ipad and does not let go like it's a
strong magnet pattern matching up to the
ipad then there's a hinge which is like
this long metal tube through the middle
with a usb type-c pass-through port on
the side for charging then a base which
is this silicon rubberized material
we've seen in apple cases before with a
full-size backlit keyboard and trackpad
and it's a lot of material it's a bit
thicker and heavier also than you might
be imagining you ready for this ipad pro
weighs this big one 640 grams
and then without the ipad the case by
itself
weighs another 702 grams so it weighs
more than the ipad so combined they are
thicker and heavier than a macbook air
and so while it's not nearly as elegant
to open and close like a laptop would be
the one thing you can say about this
case is it is well built so to get this
in place basically you open this up
and quickly you find that the hinge has
this locking point
where it gets to the locking point and
it snaps into place and that's nice and
then the top part continues opening like
a hinge so you've opened it like this
you take the ipad you lock it with the
magnets into the top half
everything lights up the pins are all
connected and now it's floating above
the keyboard as advertised now we've
already seen ipad cases with keyboards
before there's plenty of people already
using them but there's a couple things
that make this one so impressive number
one is that hinge it's pretty stiff like
a laptop and it is limited in how far
back it goes but actually find it goes
just far back enough for any of my
normal use it just kind of pops off the
back and hovers the ipad there
then the keyboard is really nice i think
it's the nicest part it's scissor
switches so it has a nice travel and it
actually feels clicky like the new
macbook air and 16 inch macbook pros
keys and since the board is stiff and
well built there's actually no flex at
all unlike some laptops and then it's
backlit which no doubt sucks a little
bit of extra power from the ipad's
battery but i like the backlight it's a
nice touch it fades on and off and just
generally yeah it's it's the best
keyboard i've ever seen in an ipad case
that's facts and then of course there's
the trackpad 2. it's not the biggest
trackpad in the world like you might
find on a full-size laptop but it is
nice and it definitely completes the the
laptop computer feel with the new ios
cursor and it clicks it really
physically clicks so everywhere from
corner to corner which is nice so now
you have the ipad hovering above the
keyboard here with just enough room to
type and not really ever touch the ipad
usually for me that's good and so now it
feels like a computer the usb type-c
charging passthrough is at the bottom
like where a normal computer port would
be and i seem to be getting almost 100
efficiency through those pins which
definitely impressed me so it's like a
real
13-inch
laptop ish computer with a 120 hertz
screen
and ipad os and all of its quirks but
let me tell you there are still a lot of
quirks to this being your main computer
first of all weight management is
something we often think about with
these ipad cases in a laptop you open
this by the hinge and all the weight all
the guts in the computer are at the
bottom and the top is just a lightweight
screen so opening and closing it
pretty elegant not a whole lot of
problems there but with the ipad
in this case or any case like this the
ipad is the computer and so most of that
weight is up top and so it can feel a
little bit top-heavy this is part of why
they made this case so heavy is to try
to combat this a little bit to try to
make it feel a little bit less top-heavy
but still
it's not perfect this whole thing here
it's still lappable in some positions
that's a new word right lappable
most of the classic laptop positions are
still fine i know some people were
wondering about this it's better than
you might expect
but from experience it's still not as
flexible as a truly bottom weighted
laptop where the hinge is just moving
the screen weight and then if you get
down to the keyboard great keyboard like
i said physically speaking but there's
no escape key
so if i want to exit a full screen video
or use anything you typically escape you
have to touch the screen and you've
probably noticed by now there's no
function buttons at all on this keyboard
meaning there's no brightness
volume or even keyboard backlight
brightness shortcuts here for all that
you gotta touch the screen in fact just
to change the keyboard brightness you
have to go into the settings app into
general
into keyboard settings and then into
keyboard hardware settings and then
that's where you can manually turn up or
down the keyboard backlight brightness
luckily auto brightness is typically
still pretty good it's using the ipad's
sensors by the way so that's hopefully
not something you have to do very often
but still you get the point here and
then also i on a mac i'm a i'm a command
q person as a lot of mac people are
whenever i want to quit an app command q
to close it
it doesn't quite work the same way here
if you're in an app and you hit command
q nothing happens you have to touch the
screen or command h to go home but if
you actually do want to close an app in
your multitasking without touching the
screen shout out to peter mckinnon
actually for teaching me this you go to
the command tab menu and then find the
app you want to close in there and then
command q to close that and then you
know like normal with an ipad there's a
bunch of gestures from the trackpad and
keyboard shortcuts to learn in fact if
you hold down command at any point in
anything it'll show you a list of all
the keyboard shortcuts available to you
at that time in that app so that's a
pretty cool pro tip
but that represents a little bit of a
learning curve if you've come from
something else with a keyboard so at the
end of the day let me let me wrap it all
up with this
my macbook air spec is 1200 bucks
this ipad pro the 13 inch the same size
screen is a thousand bucks plus the 350
case that makes it
1350. now if i could only have one if i
could only have a laptop with no ipad or
this ipad keyboard case which is a bit
more expensive but no laptop
i really want to say i would rather have
this i'd rather have like the ability to
pop off and have an ipad at any time and
then when i want to type i got the
keyboard and i can go back and forth and
it's much more fun it's 120 hertz it's
got way more apps there's cameras if i
need them this is just more fun
but i still need that laptop sometimes
and for me that's especially when
multitasking like if i'm writing the
review on the keyboard and i have
spotify playing in the background and i
just want to skip to the next song
there's no button for it i have to go
over into spotify and then swipe and
then come
like have you ever tried to be on a zoom
call
and take notes at the same time in an
ipad
good luck it's not it doesn't work but
all that being said in ipad land there
are two types of people in this world
those who get a case or a folio or a
keyboard for their ipad and they keep it
in it all the time they never take it
out that's just the way the ipad is now
or those who get a key keyboard or case
and pop it out and use it mostly like an
ipad all the time and then sometimes
they need a type so they'll pop it in
here type away it becomes a typing
machine then when they're done pop it
back out use it as an ipad again
for that second type of person
this setup this accessory is the best
possible version of the ipad this is a
go this is awesome
go for it spring the 300 bucks
but for me
i'm not getting rid of my laptop
but that's been it
thanks for watching
catch you guys the next one peace